you got very good at jiu jitsu
very fast so you want i mean you told
the story blue belt and so on but you
went to black belt
really quickly uh and not just in terms
of ranks but in terms of just skill
level
i mean uh you didn't go to black belt
nearly as fast as
your skill set developed you were like
doing extremely well at high level
competition
so you're a good person to ask how does
one
get good at jiu jitsu we talked about
solving problems at the elite level but
when you're a beginner at the at the
martial arts
how do you get good how much training
should you do
the very basic stuff like how much
training how much drilling
okay and then the mental stuff like
where should your mind be how should you
approach it from a mental perspective
too i'll just tell you my perspective on
this one i guess i would say
uh i feel step one i feel lucky to have
found uh
you know a good training situation
particularly for the time
um you know in uh in where in where i
was at
and uh i drilled a ton um i drilled and
drilled and drilled and drilled and
drilled
and one one thing that's really
important to understand
though is that it i was able to in a
relatively brief period of years go
go from zero to reasonably good but um
i think i probably crammed more hours in
those
small years than most people did
training let's let's say in two or three
times the length so
it may not it may masquerade as
something else other than it is i i
could say
you have to put it in the hours yeah
there's no way around that i think so
what did you put in those so when you
said drilling can you break that apart a
little bit like what
what what does really look like is there
any recommendations absolutely step one
i would say your choices matter
like uh there's a i think one of the
really important things that i think we
should consider about jiu jitsu is that
there's a lot of junk in the system
right now it's like jujitsu has
exploded in terms of uh the number of
positions techniques
strategies this that rule sets that's
really cool on the one hand on the other
hand there's
probably a just metric ton of
sub-optimal things that are out there
that are being taught
um my myself included i've taught things
that are looking back five years three
years two years one year or i'm like oh
i would not do it like that anymore
straight up sometimes i wouldn't do it
like that other times i would literally
never do even that particular movement
um i don't think the shrimp is a real
move
uh it's like it's a giant speeling it's
easier to show in person but long sword
of is there's a lot of things that are
we think of as fundamental that i think
that are uh
really pretty negative and also you know
um that's heresy and jiu-jitsu
isn't it the shrimp exactly is like the
holy
we all worship the shrimp we love the
shrimp we love the shrimp
now for people who don't do jiu jitsu
and you should
the shrimp is uh you scoot your butt
away from your opponent yeah in a real
description
it's like a really athletic looking
position where you look like like
someone that's trying to stick their
butt out on instagram
and then you push your hands away and
you expose your face
and then uh you lay on your side because
someone told you to do that
and you look like uh yeah i guess you
look like a shrimp
yeah it's like that time that uh you
know someone really credible told me to
drink unleaded gasoline and i did it for
a while
and then uh you know it got to the point
in my life where you know the next best
the thing that i needed to do to really
improve my life was stop
drinking unleaded gasoline yes and uh i
would say that there's like a lot of
stuff that's
that's in there that step one is like uh
it's junk it's actual junk and it's it's
not only
will it waste your time it's it will
straight up it will it will be like an
albatross hanging on you because it
affects how you think about things going
forward so although
um it was it's funny like the operating
assumptions that
we we work under um have a huge huge
huge influence you mentioned like
growing up in the united states or this
being a capitalist society like
all right now of course i think that i
don't really know any different
otherwise and i think that a lot of
times people go oh
communism is better i'm like haven't
seen it read any books about it being
better
but uh it's possible i mean i haven't
experienced it much myself
either so i can't dismiss it out right
but i guess i would say it's a
fundamentally different
differing operating system underpinning
and all of my choices all of
if i honestly believed in that thing
many of my choices
on a moment by moment on a day by day
and certainly on a lifetime basis
would be very different so i would say
that uh it's tough when you're
when you're young in the martial arts
and i mean all of us are always trying
to do our best to learn but when you're
young in the martial arts you always go
if you're a reasonable guy
what are they what they call it like
dunning kruger amnesia i can't remember
this is the right one but basically you
go like oh i know what i'm
doing here so i can say that's not right
but then i read a new story
about baseball only about baseball
sounds credible um and it's
it's yeah but i can't call
if you're a reasonable person
you can't call on things that
you don't understand even if you suspect
it's not right you're like well i've got
to reserve judgment
you never ever ever set aside your your
need and also obligation to understand
why you were doing what you're doing and
don't ask why once ask why over and over
and over
and over about the same thing oh well i
want to shrimp why
to make space why do i want to make
space to get away from the guy well why
do i want to get away from him
well because he's dangerous why is he
dangerous and you can oftentimes get
down to wait a minute i didn't even need
to move three quarters of the time
you're actually acting in the other
person's self-interest and
i guess a lot of times i can't this kind
of goes beyond what we can
you know demonstrate here but i would
just say uh trying to understand
what my base operating assumptions are
and consistently re-evaluate them which
can be freaking exhausting frankly and
also consonants confidence destroying
but you mentioned uh that that i did
pretty well relatively quickly i was at
um i started in 2004 and i was at abu
dhabi adcc for the first time as an
alternate in 2007
i won a match there against the
blackboard world champion um
and uh the fact frankly the fact that i
was able to beat someone like that was
neat but at the same time says a little
bit more about
what jiu jitsu is and some of the issues
with it than it does about how cool
i am was because that
shouldn't really happen when you think
about it you're like okay you're a
champion
at ostensibly a very high level of the
sport
you enjoy a three inch four inch height
advantage and a
35 pound weight advantage and you just
got beat like that
should not exist i'm serious i'm dead
serious that should not exist if that
happens you're doing it wrong is it that
i'm doing it right or is it that you're
doing it wrong and there's enough
variance in the way that you're doing it
that you're allowing me to win and now i
did happen to win that with the 50 50
heel hook which was
50 50. but um but basically which was
one of the early examples of
like hey guys by the way people can try
to hurt your legs and that was something
like uh we mentioned john danaher
mentioned like you know myself
dean lister a lot of the guys from the
hanzo grace team that have had amazing
success they've gone and done
great things um and your craig jones in
the competitive grappling world
basically taking advantage of being very
very good in what they're doing but also
a glaring
glaring glaring issue with the operating
system of jiu jitsu
which was you know a huge vulnerability
in the lower body
and not only not attacking it but having
no idea how one does attack
it which means you can't understand how
someone will assail you so anyway um
i i guess to come back is if in the in
the absence of knowing what to do i try
to polish what i've got so if i've got a
knife and i'm like i don't know how to
use them
okay i'm just gonna sharpen the edge and
polish it and make sure that when i need
to use this to anything i'll be able to
do it
because trying to put together a system
when you don't
have an idea of what's going on a lot of
times you end up making
you know some optimal choices but as
long as you're consistently
re-evaluating what you're doing and
that's something i've tried to do over
time
over and over and over again and try to
seek out the uh
the most um the best and also most uh
um articulate or insightful instructors
or people of various love doesn't matter
if they're well known or not that could
say hey ryan i think you should do this
i think you should do that
and i i think all i've ever done in
martial arts is try to treat people with
respect honestly
try to demonstrate appreciation for the
many many people who have helped me over
time and be the type of person that they
want to train with
not the type of because we've all
trained with people that make us think
about beating the
ever-loving crap in them i never wanted
to be that guy and i was basically
saying like if if i train with a black
belt when i'm a blue belt and
and this person enjoys training with me
that's in my interest selfishly not only
do i not want them to beat me up but
selfishly i should
you mentioned being decent to other
people you want to incentivize being
decent to other people right with the
structure of what you're doing
selfishly i'm incentivized to be a nice
guy even if i'm
internally a scumbag which i like to
think that i'm not but basically uh
going like hey this guy's way more
likely to help me or this person's way
more likely to help me if i shake their
hand
say thank you i really appreciate you
helping me out and uh
that thing that they tapped me with four
or five times i'm gonna ask them about
it
and then they don't have to tell me
they're under no obligation but i'll say
and will they tell me don't thank you so
much for your time i really appreciate
it
and uh that that's it you know okay so
to summarize those so
what you brilliantly described i just
want to make sure we're keeping track i
went all over the place
no you didn't you're you're pretty on
point but uh so the first thing is
basically which is difficult i wonder if
we can break it apart a little bit
is don't trust authority essentially
keep asking why
be respectful without trusting authority
right right which is and then the second
thing is be the kind of person that
others like training with or like being
around
sort of uh being a good
friend so so many people just enjoy
being around so one is
complete which is yeah you're right it's
the tension which is like completely
disrespect the
the way that things are done so asking
why constantly
one of it is your own flaws and not
understanding the fundamentals of what's
being described
and then once you get good enough not
understanding
um like going against the fact that the
instructor doesn't understand and my
inability to understand what you're
saying though doesn't invalidate it and
that's something like you mentioned like
keeping in mind our own flaws and then
also again the flaws that any of us have
is the instructor to your point and i
guess
i can speak to being kind of weird i
don't you know i like to
sit in the corner but um so everyone's a
little bit different some people
you know i wasn't terribly popular in
high school i you know like uh
i don't like high school very much but
anyway yeah i would
not gonna be rude to people though i was
never gonna bully anybody
if you said hello to me i'd say hello
back i would hold the door for you if
you walk by
you know and i would just say like
simple things like that
go a long long long way and that
actually takes us back to our uh
um to our social discussion where i'm
like oh man how do i become great at jiu
jitsu it's like well i'll start by
not pissing off this person who can beat
the crap out of me and not disrespecting
the person
who is probably the clearest the closest
thing to a font of knowledge
at that time for me so and then
recognizing that
i should do that for its own virtue
because it's the right thing to do and i
should try to treat people decently but
beyond
that even selfishly it's in my interest
to do that
but see the thing is this this is
interesting
is um there's a culture and martial arts
a culture that i like where the
instructor legitimately so
carries a aura of authority
and it's not comfortable to really ask
why i'm not it's a skill to be able to
have a discussion as a white belt the
black belt instructor
of like why is it done this way
like and saying why again
like with i mean it's a skill to show
that you're actually
legitimately a curious and passionate
and compassionate
student versus like somebody who's just
being an annoying dick
who saw some stuff on youtube there's a
line between
to walk there i i just wonder because
like
it's the drilling thing and you know i
um for example like in my and
when i was coming up there was so much
emphasis placed on like closed guard for
example
and you might you might actually teach
me now i
i don't know but to me it was like why
do i need to
master the close guard like why is the
closed guard
on top or the bottom but the bottom
really this is the fundamental basics of
jiu jitsu
who decided that my body is not
my body says this is wrong i'm like
this like i have short legs but doesn't
even matter the length of legs
there's something about me that just i
don't understand how leverage here works
for
my particular body like
so it's just it's a feel thing too like
it feels like in my basic understanding
of leverage and movement and timing and
so on it feels like these certain like
butterfly guard or even like half
basically every guard except coast guard
i i can
play i can dance closed guard feels like
you're shutting down uh like the play
that is that wrong
or is that make sure that's what you
want because that's almost like an
innate characteristic
of this guard position but it's not sold
that way right it's like hey this is a
good guard
that's like hey man here's a bow and
arrow versus
and you know how to use this thing right
like make sure you're you're far away
and like up on a hill or something
because you could take that bone out run
up on something and try to use it
but if nobody told you not to do that
and they told you it's foundational it's
very foundational it's very important to
everything else too
right that's back to the shrimping thing
how many things are we taught
that even if it's not let's say itself
is not a
garbage thing it might be effectively
garbage
you could give me a ferrari but if i try
to make it fly
it's not going to work if you're like
here's a plane here's another plane
here's another plane here's another
plane here's a ferrari i'm like oh it
must be a different type of plane
like you could be forgiven for for leap
if we're going there you know like oh
maybe the wings come out or you just go
fast enough there's like a bullet like
you can make these crazy leaps in your
mind and people are doing that
all the time so if you don't provide the
context for me
or worse yet you provide improper
context like
how how much of a problem is that going
to be well
i think the skill of the white belt
should be just be nice
but so in the complicated human space of
when your intention at least on the in
the big picture of you
is good there's the question is it's not
always when your intention is good
the actual implementation of it
is good so you might be just almost and
and that's much it's not the case for
you it's much more the case for white
belts
they don't even know their intention
might be good but they don't know all
the lines they're crossing all the
right so they're not actually able to
and like interpret
all the ways in which they're being
totally insensitive to the requests of
others like
explicit requests of others so your job
as a beginner
is to be a really good listener of those
social cues
it's like a visitor in a foreign country
right yeah like you're a representative
of people that look like you people that
talk like you people that have your
passport and you're like man i'm going
to go over here oh i've got my foot up
on my knee well if i was in certain
conscious world that's rude
i'm like oh i'm so sorry but can you
imagine if someone says hey i really
appreciate you take your foot off that's
pretty rude and then i want to tell them
well not where i'm from man
i'm in your house i better again i may
go that direction but let's see i could
get away with that now i'm a bully
and if i can't get away with that well
i'm about to maybe be on the wrong side
of something but i i guess uh
like you said if we have positive
intention that's fine but i also have to
recognize who i am and i think that
that's one thing that
i tried to do and continue to try to do
over time like we're
oh man uh hi i'm i'm the one that's
asking for a favor here if i spawn with
raymond daniels raymond daniel's doing
me a favor
i ain't doing him a favor let's not get
it twisted so
thank you so much for tom i really
appreciate these are not and this is not
like some affected nonsense this is
serious i'm like thank you if i spawn
with stephen thompson i'm i'm the one
being done a favor george st pierre
takes his time to spar with me which he
has in the past
and and not even kill me which is really
i appreciate that because that's why i
can sit here
george is not a prop for me to to to get
my rocks off or see what's going on and
also
i'm gonna do that and then expect him to
just take it and i've seen
he's a gentleman i've seen people get
nuts with george and and have him just
like
he has a he's a patient of a saint i
don't have that level of patience but i
would just say to come back
what figuring out like hey so what what
role am i here and that comes back to
like at least what i see people on the
internet yeah man i have a beef with joe
rogan you're like
no you don't ryan you're some goof yeah
i'm like i'm some random dude joe
like people want it they almost want to
like elevate so that we can somehow be
level we're peers here if i go into
frosta hobbies gym i'm not a peer
frosted hobby i am a student of tristar
i am a guest in the academy and if for
us asked me for something
short of him like you know telling me to
try to do a triple backflip so i break
my neck
the answer is yes sir i can do it for
you for us no man no worries and it's
and hopefully it should come
with i guess a level of graciousness but
i guess that's kind of one of the things
that i see nowadays with uh
how accessible people are because i grew
up you know being a big huge baseball
sports fan of all kinds
i couldn't send derek jeter a message
and and much less have a possibility of
a reply
and if i do it's like you know i have
people send me messages it's very nice
that people say message some people
again and everyone not everyone is
coming from the same place
but i've had plenty of things they're
like yo dude i need you to do this for
me i'm like
well i'll tell you what's never going to
happen that i have no idea who you are
and that was
how i was addressed and i don't need oh
man you're the greatest one because
that's weird and two because i'm not
but just hey ryan uh how are you doing
um hey
if you think you could do the following
if you get a second like if i get a
second you're dang right i can't why not
it's easy ask
but it would it started with some level
of politeness and i guess like that's
maybe being semi-southern like i grew up
in virginia yes sir yes ma'am like
yeah well there's all different kinds of
implementations of politics i mean all
most of the successful people i've met
it's been surprising to me
how much of you you mentioned peers
like the like i could think of joe rogan
you mentioned joe rogan but
elon musk they
don't like they almost treat me like i'm
the superior
you know what i mean like it's not even
it's it's that's the politeness
like you know that's the approach the
feeling of it is like i'm the student
i'm the beginner i'm like approaching a
situation like
it's it's uh it's almost like
uh method acting of like you're better
than me
that and that's how i approach a lot of
interactions like i have something to
learn from this even if it's like a
young
do you think that they're ungenuine
they're totally genuine
but it's not a funny thing like in spite
of who they are they're incredibly
genuine because they respect correct me
if i'm wrong they respect you obviously
for what you bring to the table
no
with dignity as a human being as a human
being which is right people
when they could probably get away with
treating most people without a whole
heck of a lot of dignity and i guess
what does that always say that like you
know again like you can always tell
someone of of
you know of quality because they treat
the king and the and the janitor the
same way
but that's what we're seeing a lot like
like that's i guess i don't mean to like
to nitpick but that's where
take issue i guess a little bit or
disagree with are you gonna criticize
with the
the internet again i know people on the
internet oh man yells it yells at clouds
but uh but um anyway but i guess uh
what what i mean is just like the way
that people address each other because
it's so casual now
yes you know and it's like it's great on
the one hand it's nice on the other hand
you go hey
i just why can't do am i somehow
demanding am i worried about diminishing
myself it's like the way that i'm sure
that people talk to like talk to women
sometimes
and words yo what's up girl oh man she's
you know versus like how am i that was
supposed to get a good response
what about that was going to elicit a
favorable response
you know versus being anything anything
other than than just
yo man what's going on and i guess that
does that make any sense it makes total
sense and that southern thing that
you're referring to i
i feel like that's an important uh
that's an important part of human
communication
you